having a baby
means the world to me is everything i've
always wanted congrats are in order one
thousand pound sister star amy slayton
welcomes baby number two and the reality
star is soaking up all the love here's
amy with her husband michael as she
introduces their new addition to the
world revealing they had a baby boy
named glenn allen halterman weighing
five pounds 11 ounces and 17.5 inches
long and as if baby glenn wasn't already
the cutest thing we've seen all day your
heart will melt over big brother gage
meeting him for the first time check out
the one-year-old in awe of his little
bro
but it must have been cuteness overload
for gage because later he took a cat nap
on amy's nephew braxton the proud mom
wrote on instagram true love right here
gage being a big brother the couple
welcomed their first son back in
november 2020 and amy documented her
pregnancy on season two of their tlc
series i'm pregnant
are you serious i told him to check it
four times
but there's so many unknowns with this
pregnancy
anything could go wrong
it was definitely an unexpected
pregnancy for amy as doctors warned the
reality star of the risk involved with
conceiving just four months after her
weight loss surgery
it's only been a couple months since i
had the surgery and dr proctor told me
not to get pregnant for two years
oops
even though amy's lost a lot of weight
she's still a very high risk pregnancy
at 288 pounds plus this is going to put
a huge damper on her overall weight loss
there's a tendency to say hey i'm
pregnant we can eat whatever we want to
and for you this is in the middle of a
big weight loss journey it's unclear
what amy's diet was like when baby glenn
butt fans got a glimpse of her unique
cravings while pregnant with gage
this is sour gummies on my chip
oh my god this is so good
the baby is going crazy with sour
gummies it loves sour gummies it's so
bad my tongue is bleeding even her
sister tammy couldn't quite wrap her
head around amy's unconventional food
combos y'all taste buzzer
i got more of the fine palate what about
lasagna and pineapples
are you
this is like a dream come true i hope no
my real italian people see this like in
italy and stuff
well that's hard to watch we love seeing
amy and michael happy with their growing
family
[Music]